Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue dans un nouveau podcast.
Ça fait un moment parce que le week-end dernier, j'étais avec ma femme
à un événement en Allemagne et donc je n'ai pas pu enregistrer de podcast.
Mais voilà, aujourd'hui un nouveau podcast et pour le sujet d'aujourd'hui,
je me posais la question en fait de…
enfin j'ai essayé de savoir pourquoi est-ce
que l'apprentissage des langues c'est devenu quelque chose d'important
pour moi, pourquoi ça a eu de l'importance et en fait en y réfléchissant,
j'ai compris que ça avait de l'importance parce que j'ai passé beaucoup
de temps à apprendre notamment le japonais et du coup aujourd'hui j'avais envie
de parler de ça et je pense que le titre de la vidéo ce sera quelque chose
comme la vraie valeur c'est le temps.
Ce qui a de la valeur, c'est ce sur quoi on passe du temps.
Donc voilà, aujourd'hui je vais parler de ça et je vais parler de ça en plusieurs parties.
Dans une première partie je vais parler de l'argent parce que quand on pense à la valeur,
on pense dans un premier temps à l'argent.
Dans une deuxième partie je vais parler de tout ce qui est résultat
et un peu culte de la performance qu'on peut avoir aussi dans l'apprentissage des langues.
Et enfin dans la dernière partie je
finirai, je vais conclure le podcast
sur le fait que le temps c'est la vraie valeur.
c'est la vraie valeur qu'on donne aux choses.
Donc voilà, vous avez un peu la structure, j'ai écrit quelques idées,
donc vous avez la structure de la vidéo et peut-être
que je mettrai des chapitres YouTube au cas où vous avez envie d'aller
voir une seule partie.
J'ai des idées, mais je vais parler sans
script, donc peut-être
que ça vaut le coup de tout regarder.
Si jamais avant de commencer, merci
aux personnes qui ont rejoint,
qui sont devenus membres YouTube, merci pour le soutien.
Il y a d'autres vidéos réservées aux membres qui vont
sortir et vous allez aussi avoir le script
de cette vidéo disponible gratuitement
sur Patreon ainsi que des PDF avec la liste de vocabulaire,
des exercices et des corrections disponibles pour les membres payant seulement.
Donc si vous voulez me soutenir, vous pouvez devenir membre c'est quatre dollars
par mois sur YouTube ou sur Patreon.
Les deux, je fais en sorte que les deux aient les mêmes avantages.
Donc vous choisissez la plateforme qui est la plus pratique
pour vous si vous voulez devenir membre, bien évidemment.
Et donc, on est parti pour le sujet de cette vidéo.
La vraie valeur, c'est le temps.
La première partie, j'ai noté ça "l'argent".
Quand on pense à la valeur, on pense surtout à l'argent.
Et c'est normal, on vit dans un monde capitaliste et quels
que soient les...
régime politique des pays, démocratie,
dictature ou autocratie,
enfin je ne vais pas lister
toutes les structures politiques, parce que je ne les connais pas toutes,
mais quelque soit un peu le système politique d'un pays, ce qu'on a tous
en commun, c'est l'argent.
C'est-à-dire que l'argent, c'est la valeur commune et avec l'argent,
vous pouvez acheter des choses, etc.
Et du coup, c'est vrai qu'on est dans
un monde où la valeur universelle,
c'est l'argent et donc si vous avez beaucoup d'argent,
vous pouvez faire beaucoup de choses.
L'argent, c'est une sorte de liberté et du coup,
on a tendance à tout mesurer selon l'argent.
tous les objets ont de la valeur.
Si je vous montre ça, c'est la batterie de la caméra.
Vous allez connaître, vous pouvez connaître sa valeur.
Là, j'ai un livre.
Qui a une certaine valeur etc donc tout a
de la valeur et enfin tout à une valeur monétaire donc une valeur basée
sur la monnaie une monnaie c'est par exemple le dollars, ou l'euro,
ou le...
le Yen, le Yuan, etc.
Et donc ça, c'est la valeur monétaire, et tout à une valeur,
c'est-à-dire que...
n'importe où où vous allez, vous allez pouvoir acheter quelque chose
avec de l'argent.
Du coup, quand on utilise le terme valeur
en général, on pense automatiquement à l'argent.
Et en plus, l'argent, c'est mesurable.
Comment dire.
C'est-à-dire que tout a une valeur monétaire.
Je sais pas si l'idée de cette vidéo est très bonne,
peut-être que ça va être un peu compliqué à expliquer, mais je pense
que c'est intéressant.
tout est mesurable et finalement, en fait, quand c'est mesurable,
c'est rassurant.
Quand on peut mesurer les choses, c'est rassurant.
Et ça, c'est bête, mais c'est...
comme quand vous voulez acheter par exemple une caméra, quand au moment où j'ai regardé
pour acheter une caméra, je comparais les différentes offres,
les différents produits que je pouvais acheter, et finalement,
le prix, ça me donnait quand même une indication, c'est-à-dire
que je me disais, cette caméra vaut plus cher, c'est sûrement mieux,
etc.
Et du coup, tout est mesurable.
Et ça, c'est pareil pour notre propre vie, c'est-à-dire que...
En général, dans la vie, on dit il faut être heureux.
Le problème du bonheur, c'est que c'est difficilement mesurable.
Alors que quand on dit"cette année, je gagne tant d'argent,
j'ai un salaire de tant et l'année prochaine,
je gagne plus d'argent", c'est très mesurable
et techniquement on va se dire"ah ben c'est très bien".
Le bonheur ce n'est pas du tout mesurable et du coup...
C'est moins, on a moins cette vision très chiffrée, en fait,
l'argent, c'est vraiment des chiffres.
Donc, si demain, j'ai plus d'argent sur mon compte en banque,
je vais me dire, c'est une bonne nouvelle.
Et ça, c'est rassurant parce qu'on n'a pas besoin de trop se poser
de questions pour savoir ce qui coûte cher ou pas.
Et c'est pareil, je veux dire.
c'est un peu pareil
Je pense que c'est...
Je ne sais pas comment dire, mais en fait j'ai l'impression
que sur les réseaux sociaux etc, ça tourne beaucoup autour
de ça,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a beaucoup de contenus
ou ça va être des contenus très matérialistes par exemple.
En France, on a un peu le cliché des ... ce qu'on appelle les influenceurs qui sont à Dubaï.
Donc, c'est les influenceurs– souvent, c'est un peu le terme péjoratif
dans ce cas-là– qui partent vivre à Dubaï pour ne pas payer d'impôts en France,
etc.
Et souvent, l'image qu'on a de Dubaï, de ces influenceurs à Dubaï,
c'est des personnes qui ont des voitures de luxe,
qui achètent des choses très chères tout le temps.
Et ça, ça devient un peu un modèle, j'ai l'impression.
C'était déjà le cas avant où il
y avait des personnes très riches qui
avaient déjà un jet privé, etc.
Et on a un peu ce truc…
On a un peu l'impression que ça, c'est la vie parfaite, en fait.
Et tout simplement parce que c'est mesurable.
Ces personnes, elles ont un jet privé, une voiture de luxe,
etc.
On se dit, ça doit être vraiment la belle vie.
Ça, c'est la question, c'est une question...
C'est la question, est-ce que l'argent fait le bonheur?
Et c'est une question qu'on aime bien poser en France
parce qu'on a un rapport à l'argent qui est plutôt compliqué,
je pense.
On a l'image des États-Unis où vous pouvez parler d'argent très ouvertement.
En France, ce n'est pas le cas, et du coup, souvent, les personnes qui sont
riches en France, on aime bien leur poser ce genre de questions,
et en fait, il n'y a pas vraiment de bonnes réponses.
Pour ma part, je pense que l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur,
parce que sinon, il n'y aurait pas de...
de personnes riches qui...
sont en dépression ou etc.
Disons que si on dit « l'argent fait le bonheur », ça veut dire
que c'est quelque chose d'automatique, or ce n'est pas du tout le cas.
Je pense que ça offre une grande liberté, avoir beaucoup d'argent,
ça offre une grande liberté.
Et après, qu'est-ce qu'on fait de cette liberté pour être heureux?
C'est très
philosophique,
mais je ne m'éloigne pas trop du sujet
initial qui est la vraie valeur c'est le temps.
Et du coup, on est un peu dans ce monde où tout est un peu une question d'argent.
Et ce qui est normal, c'est-à-dire que par exemple, moi je dis souvent
que je suis allé au Japon pendant un an, ça, il n'y a pas de secret,
j'avais mis de l'argent de côté, j'avais économisé pour partir un an au Japon
et donc j'ai beau dire que l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur,
etc.
Si j'ai pu partir, c'est parce que j'avais gagné suffisamment d'argent
avant dans mon travail précédent.
Donc voilà, je pense qu'il ne faut pas non plus dire...
Enfin.
En France, on peut avoir un peu ce discours, gagner trop d'argent,
c'est pas bien, etc.
ou trop opposer dire
que l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur, etc.
La réalité, c'est que dans un monde capitaliste, ça offre quand même énormément
de possibilités.
D'ailleurs, je crois que pour mesurer un peu ce propos, mesurer ce
que je viens de dire, c'est que je crois qu'il y avait une étude qui disait
qu'en fait notre bonheur augmentait avec l'argent jusqu'à un
certain seuil et qu'après, ça n'avait plus aucun effet sur notre niveau de bonheur.
Typiquement, pouvoir aller faire ses courses sans regarder le prix
sans être trop inquiet de son budget, déjà,
forcément ça participe à être plus...
à être moins stressé, à être un peu plus...
un peu plus libre d'esprit concernant les problèmes financiers qu'on peut avoir.
Mais du coup, l'argent,
c'est la valeur universelle parce que c'est mesurable et c'est rassurant
que ce soit mesurable, on peut tout comparer.
Et j'ai l'impression que quand on transpose ça à des activités
comme l'apprentissage d'une langue, on a un peu les mêmes mécanismes,
c'est-à-dire que...
Je ne sais pas si c'est quelque chose de récent, mais j'ai l'impression
que sur les réseaux sociaux il y a beaucoup de ça,
mais où ça va être des contenus qui sont très orientés résultats
et un peu culte de la performance.
C'est-à-dire que vous ouvrez les réseaux sociaux, ça va être un peu le concours
de"ah, j'ai appris..."
Enfin, si on parle de l'apprentissage des langues, ça va être"ah,
j'ai appris 14 langues en trois jours, je suis devenu fluent."
Ça va être "ah, j'ai créé mon propre site web et j'ai gagné 1 million
de dollars le 1er mois."
Et ça va être beaucoup de choses comme ça qui présentent seulement le résultat.
C'est vraiment le résultat et la performance qui compte, et ce qui est derrière
finalement, ce n'est plus vraiment intéressant.
Et ça, je pense que c'est relié un peu aussi à ce truc de c'est mesurable,
c'est-à-dire que quand on dit...
quand on donne un résultat, les gens peuvent se dire que c'est bien ou ce n'est pas bien.
Personnellement, quand je dois expliquer mon métier, je dis je suis professeur de français
et je crée du contenu et là les gens ils se disent bon ...
Ouais, enfin je vois c'est intéressant mais sans plus et après,
si je veux être plus factuel, être factuel c'est donner des faits,
je vais dire par exemple, sur YouTube j'ai 12 000 abonnés,
ce n'est pas beaucoup.
Mais disons que, et je ne dis pas ça pour me vanter, mais disons
que quand je dis ça, les gens comprennent, enfin, mesurent plus
rapidement ce dont je parlais, ils se disent"ah ouais 12 000 personnes c'est pas mal etc"
et du coup ils arrivent un peu à mesurer, savoir si c'est bien
ou si c'est pas bien, enfin ça c'est très binaire comme façon
de voir les choses, mais disons que c'est tout de suite ça donne,
les résultats donnent un peu une idée
et c'est rassurant d'avoir quelque chose où on peut se
dire"ah oui 12 000 c'est bien mais c'est moins bien que 20 000 forcément,
c'est moins bien que 50 000".
Alors qu'en réalité, ce qu'il y a
derrière, finalement on ne s'y intéresse pas vraiment
et du coup
Sur les réseaux sociaux on a énormément de choses comme ça,
de contenus comme ça qui parlent de développement personnel,
de coach, qui disent...
Pareil pour l'apprentissage des langues,
vous avez des influenceurs qui disent « passez de niveau A1 à B2
en quatre mois ».
C'est possible, c'est possible, mais du coup on présente surtout le résultat avant
de présenter en quoi ça consiste.
Enfin, mais d'un côté c'est normal,
enfin je veux dire c'est du marketing basique et quand on veut apprendre une langue,
on cherche à avoir un résultat et du coup quand on tombe sur ce genre
de...
de phrases, on se dit c'est sûrement efficace et je vais aller plutôt
sur ce service-là.
Donc d'un côté, c'est tout à fait normal et ce n'est pas une mauvaise chose
parce que quand on apprend une langue, on a besoin d'avoir des résultats.
Si vous apprenez mais que vous ne remarquez aucune progression,
vous allez abandonner tout simplement.
Sur les téléphones, moi sur mon application, j'ai un streak
de nombre de jours consécutifs,
j'ai le nombre de mots que je connais qui augmentent un peu chaque jour,
et ces résultats me permettent de voir que je progresse.
Donc, ça, c'est important.
Le seul problème, je pense que c'est quand ça devient...
quand ça devient, quand ce culte de la performance devient la seule raison
pour laquelle on fait des choses.
Et j'ai un peu l'impression que les réseaux sociaux, ça nous donne un peu cette image.
On a accès à plein
de contenus où les gens font plein de choses différentes et il y a des gens talentueux
dans tous les domaines.
Et en fait, quand on voit ça, on a un peu, je pense que ça nous donne un peu cette idée
que quand on commence quelque chose, il faut forcément devenir très bon,
très vite, sans même se poser la question de « est-ce qu'on aime vraiment ça?».
Si je prends l'exemple de la musique, par exemple, maintenant,
vous allez vite avoir des contenus qui vous disent"
ah, j'ai fait cette musique", elle a fait X millions de streams,
par exemple.
Et ça, j'ai l'impression que quand on va commencer quelque chose,
on va se dire"ah mais derrière, si j'arrive à avoir beaucoup
de streams avec ma musique sur Spotify, par exemple, ça va être bien,
etc."
Et du coup, quand on devient trop
obsédé par ce truc de la performance,
on oublie presque de prendre du plaisir à faire ce qu'on fait,
à profiter et à se demander si on aime bien ça ou pas.
Et ça, je pense que c'est important à faire attention que tout ce qui est performance,
coach, etc., les conseils qu'on peut trouver sur les réseaux sociaux,
il faut que ça reste un moyen d'atteindre des objectifs, mais
que ça ne devienne pas le moteur, enfin, la raison pour laquelle on fait quelque chose.
Je pense que quand vous apprenez une langue, il faut réussir
bien évidemment à chercher à progresser, mais il faut surtout bien faire
en sorte, enfin, être sûr,
s'assurer que vous gardez un peu ce
truc de, en fait, j'ai l'impression d'apprendre
de plus en plus, j'ai l'impression de comprendre de plus en plus,
et c'est de ça qu'on tire vraiment de la satisfaction, c'est de vraiment l'apprentissage
en lui-même qu'on va tirer la satisfaction, qui va nous permettre
de continuer et là d'atteindre des objectifs.
Mais voilà, il faut faire attention, je pense, à ne pas, pas
que ce truc de la performance, ce truc mesurable devienne vraiment la...
la raison première pour laquelle on fait quelque chose, c'est
important de...
C'est important de...
de se poser la question, comment progresser, etc.,
mais il ne faut pas que ça devienne une obsession.
Il ne faut pas qu'on finisse par devenir obsédé par ce truc de la performance,
je pense.
Bien évidemment, il y a des cas particuliers.
Je veux dire, si vous avez un examen dans trois mois, alors là,
il faut se poser la question du résultat.
Là, c'est vraiment ce qui prime, c'est vraiment la priorité
parce que vous avez besoin d'avoir un résultat.
Mais je pense que pour la plupart d'entre vous, vous apprenez le français
parce que comme un hobby, parce que vous avez envie d'apprendre,
etc.,
et je pense que dans ce cas-là, dans ce cas de figure,
il faut faire attention à ne pas être obsédé par la performance.
Sinon, on perd un peu de vue le pourquoi on fait quelque chose.
La raison pour laquelle vous avez commencé à apprendre le français.
Et du coup, ça m'amène à la troisième partie, qui est le sujet de cette vidéo,
qui est que le temps, c'est la vraie valeur qu'on donne aux choses.
J'expliquais que...
Voilà, c'est pareil.
Quand je dis j'apprends le japonais, très rapidement on a envie un peu
de mesurer ce que ça veut dire, ça veut dire quoi savoir apprendre le japonais.
Est-ce que tu as un niveau fluent, est-ce que tu es A1, A2,
B1, B2, C1, C2, du coup on a vite tendance à vouloir catégoriser
pour que ce soit mesurable.
parce qu'on a envie d'attribuer un peu une valeur à ça.
Quand je dis"j'apprends le japonais", vous vous demandez peut-être,
mais il a quel niveau en japonais?
Parce qu'il nous dit ça depuis le début, mais ça se trouve,
il est vraiment nul en japonais.
Et si je vous dis, je crois que je suis à peu près au niveau B2,
là tout de suite vous vous dites"Ah, B2, c'est mieux que B1,
mais c'est moins bien que C1".
Et du coup, ça devient tout de suite mesurable.
Mais la réalité, c'est que, bien évidemment,
Si je passe cinq ans à apprendre une langue et que je suis niveau A1,
il y a un problème quelque part.
Mais la réalité, c'est que...
J'ai envie de progresser en japonais, mais la vraie valeur...
pour moi c'est le temps que j'ai passé à apprendre le japonais.
C'est devenu quelque chose d'important pour moi parce que ça fait cinq ans
que je, tous les jours à peu près, je passe un peu de temps à faire du japonais
et je pense qu'on...
On accorde de l'importance aux choses en passant du temps à faire ces choses
ou avec ces choses.
c'est pareil avec un objet.
Je pense que, quand je disais"L'argent, est-ce que l'argent fait le bonheur,
etc...",
j'ai un peu...
Ça m'est déjà arrivé d'acheter quelque chose un peu sans réfléchir.
Et finalement, quelque chose que je n'ai pas vraiment utilisé et que finalement,
cette chose-là n'a pas vraiment eu de valeur à mes yeux.
Quel que soit le prix que j'ai dépensé, quel que soit le prix
que j'ai payé pour avoir cet objet.
Si je prends par exemple le cas de l'apprentissage du Japonais,
j'ai acheté des livres de grammaire japonaise Et je n'ai jamais,
je ne les ai vraiment jamais utilisé.
Et pour moi, ces livres-là, finalement, je m'en fiche un peu, ça n'a pas vraiment
de valeur pour moi, alors que j'ai utilisé une application notamment
pour apprendre les caractères japonais qui s'appellent Wanikani.
Bon, j'ai payé aussi, mais à un
moment cette application, tous les matins,
je passais une demi-heure, une heure sur cette application
pour apprendre les caractères.
Du coup, à un moment, ça faisait littéralement partie de ma vie.
Et donc ça, là tout de suite, en passant plus de temps, quel
que soit le prix que j'ai payé pour avoir cet objet ou ce service,
j'accorde beaucoup plus de valeur.
Et c'est pareil, par exemple.
on a tous, je ne sais pas, un vélo qu'on a eu quand on était enfants,
qu'on a gardé très longtemps,
où on avait des objets comme ça qui avaient une valeur émotionnelle
complètement
indépendante de la valeur monétaire.
Et ça, je pense que c'est ... la seule raison, c'est que la valeur des choses,
finalement, elle dépend surtout du temps qu'on passe avec ces choses,
du temps qu'on passe à utiliser ces choses, et je pense que c'est
pour ça que l'apprentissage d'une langue c'est quelque chose
de très intéressant parce que c'est quelque chose que vous ne pouvez pas acheter.
Vous pouvez dépenser des milliers, des millions d'euros,
vous n'allez pas pouvoir acheter votre niveau de français.
Bien évidemment,
si vous êtes millionnaire et que vous pouvez payer un
professeur individuel tous les jours, deux heures par jour,
bien évidemment, ça va vous aider à apprendre plus rapidement.
Mais si vous ne passez pas du temps à apprendre cette langue,
quel que soit les livres que vous avez, quel que soit les applications
que vous avez, quel que soit le travail.
les professeurs que vous avez, si vous ne passez pas du temps,
vous n'allez pas apprendre.
Ça, d'un côté, ça peut être un peu frustrant, et d'un côté,
on peut avoir un peu cette envie d'être comme dans le film Matrix
ou Néo, le personnage principal, c'est un film futuriste.
Pour apprendre une capacité ou quelque chose, il y a des CD,
comme des CD qu'ils insèrent dans un ordinateur connecté au cerveau,
et les personnages peuvent apprendre des choses comme ça.
Dans le film, il y a l'exemple de Néo, le personnage principal joué par Keanu Reeves,
qui apprend le kung fu comme ça, il met un CD dans l'ordinateur,
il apprend le Kung Fu en quelques instants et après, c'est un maître Kung Fu.
Et ça, c'est vrai que quand on apprend une langue,
parfois c'est frustrant et parfois on a envie
de se dire « j'aimerais bien qu'un CD pour apprendre le français
ou le japonais existe ».
Mais la réalité, c'est que ça perdrait tout de son intérêt.
La raison pour laquelle ça a de la valeur pour vous de parler français,
de comprendre, etc.
C'est parce que ça prend du temps et que ce n'est pas quelque chose
de facile.
Vous ne pouvez pas faire un virement de 1000 euros, on va dire,
pour améliorer votre niveau de français.
Ça, on peut l'avoir, par exemple, dans des sports avec le matériel,
etc.,
où on peut se dire que je peux acheter un équipement plus...
haut de gamme, on peut l'avoir aussi avec l'apprentissage des langues,
mais à la fin ce qui compte, c'est le temps que vous passez à faire la chose,
à apprendre une langue ou à faire le sport.
Et ça, je pense que c'est pour ça que l'apprentissage des langues,
c'est devenu quelque chose d'important pour moi, c'est que depuis 5 ans,
5 ans et demi maintenant, c'est quelque chose pour lequel j'accorde beaucoup
de temps, je passe beaucoup de temps à apprendre des langues.
j'aimerais passer plus de temps, mais du coup, c'est devenu quelque chose d'important.
Quand je parle japonais, quand j'écoute du japonais et que je comprends,
Je...
comment dire...
je suis d'autant plus content que je sais que ça m'a pris du temps
pour arriver jusque là.
J'ai de la frustration parce que j'aimerais.
être meilleur.
Mais d'un autre côté, je me dis qu'il y a 5 ans, j'étais incapable
de lire,
j'étais incapable de comprendre et grâce à tout le temps que j'ai passé à faire ça,
j'ai des résultats.
J'ai aimé passer du temps et en plus, j'ai des résultats. Donc là,
ce qui a vraiment de la valeur, c'est le temps que j'ai passé
et le résultat, c'est un peu
la cerise sur le gâteau. Bien évidemment, il faut faire attention à avoir des résultats,
sinon on se décourage, on perd la motivation et on finit par arrêter.
Et ça c'est exactement le principe des habitudes.
Dans le livre atomique habits de James Clear, c'est exactement ce qu'il dit
quand il dit qu'une habitude, au bout d'un moment, ça fait partie
de notre identité.
notre identité, elle dépend du temps qu'on passe à faire des choses,
elle ne dépend pas de...
Bon, là, c'est mon avis, mais elle ne dépend pas de nos biens matériels.
Ce n'est pas parce que...
Hum.
j'essaye de trouver un exemple.
j'avais envie de prendre l'exemple de faire un don à une association
mais c'est un peu, je pense que c'est un exemple un peu compliqué.
Mais disons qu'en fait, est-ce que ce qui a le plus de valeur,
est-ce que je fais un don de 1 000 euros à une association
ou est-ce que je vais passer du temps pour travailler pour cette association?
Bon, je pense que c'est un exemple un peu bancal mais vous comprenez l'idée,
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut avoir le sentiment qu'avec
l'argent on peut faire des choses très bien
mais ce qui compte vraiment à la fin c'est le temps qu'on passe à faire des choses.
Et...
Et quel que soit l'argent que vous ayez ou ce genre de choses finalement,
ce qui définit
votre personnalité, votre personne, c'est le temps
que vous passez à faire des choses.
Si tous les jours, vous faites du sport, on va dire, vous êtes un sportif.
Si tous les jours, vous faites, vous apprenez du français,
on va dire, vous aimez la France,
vous êtes quelqu'un qui est intéressé par la culture française,
vous êtes quelqu'un de curieux, etc.,
etc.
Et c'est pour ça, je pense que...
On a un peu tendance à perdre de vue que la vraie valeur c'est le temps qu'on donne aux
choses ou même aux personnes.
Ça, ça peut être un autre exemple,
mais si par exemple la valeur que vous donnez à une personne,
c'est en passant du temps avec cette personne.
Vous pouvez faire des cadeaux à une personne qui coûte très cher
si vous ne passez pas de temps avec cette personne, ça risque
de ne pas avoir la même valeur.
Là, je trouve un peu des exemples au hasard.
Mais voilà, vous aurez compris l'idée.
Désolé, bon, j'ai structuré, donc ça va être un peu plus structuré
que d'habitude.
Mais c'est un sujet un peu difficile.
Ça devient presque un peu philosophique, donc j'ai voulu essayer
de garder ça un peu...
un peu simple et je n'ai même pas toutes les réponses, donc c'était plus une réflex
ion à voix haute devant la caméra.
pour un nouveau podcast cette semaine.
Donc là, avec ma femme, on a fini, on avait deux événements très rapprochés,
donc je manquais de temps pour faire des vidéos.
Là, je devrais pouvoir refaire de vidéos par semaine et je vais voir aussi
pour faire du contenu pour les membres.
Donc voilà, si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à laisser un « j'aime » et un « commentaire »
pour soutenir la chaîne et je vous dis à la
prochaine pour d'autres podcasts.
Merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout.
À la prochaine.